Guten Morgen, guten Morgen, guten Morgen Linus. Es war.
Ja, moin. Guten Morgen, Tim.
Es ist ja auch immer noch morgen, also lügen nie.
Es ist immer morgens, es ist quasi es ist im Frühtau zu Berge. Wir Podcasten.
Wenn die Lüfter der Rechner nicht so laut werden, würde man auch noch die Vögelein draußen zwitschern hören, wie sie die der Dämmerung äh ihre Hälse entgegen recken. Ja. Und ihr munteres Lied durch den Wald, pfeifen und.
Ein Tropfen Raur reift der vom Blatt herunterrinnt trinken.
Oh.
Mit der Assoziation, sprudelnder Becher und unberührter Natur äh,
begegnen wir euch hier mit den tollen Themen von Lokbuch Netzpolitik, die jetzt äh zwei hoch fünf alt ist. Zweiunddreißigste Ausgabe, ist schon was. Ist eigentlich so ein binär Geburtstag.
Geburtstag, ja. Die werden ja dann immer seltener.
Das macht sie so besonders.
Man muss sie feiern wie sie fallen.
Genau. Unser Geburtstag, der nächste wird dann erst nächstes Jahr sein und dann wird's immer schwieriger, da noch mitzuhalten. Es sei denn, wir erhöhen die Taktfrequenz. Das können wir natürlich auch machen.
Uns aber sehr.
Na gut, äh was liegt denn auf dem äh Tisch? Ein unser Lieblingsthema.
Ja also äh vielleicht wir müssen ja erstmal sagen, es gibt jetzt es gibt sehr es gibt heute eher so so weniger drastische Themen, ja. Es gibt keinen Aufreger diese Woche und wir müssen ja auch ankündigen, es wird äh im Anschluss an diese Sendung erstmal eine
kleines Päuschen bei Lokbuchnetz Politik geben.
Ein kleines, kleines Sommerpäuschen.
Zwei, drei Wochen Sommerpäuschen, weil nichts mehr passiert.
Genau, das das haben wir, wir haben in unsere Glaskugel geschaut und festgestellt, da passiert eh nichts. Da ist.
Ja, kommt nix mehr. Da lassen wir jetzt.
Genau und da muss man ja dann auch nicht unnötig sich aufregen.
Aufzuregen gibt es immer schlecht sich nicht aufzuregen.
Genau, ne? Ist ja schon fast Zeit für einen für einen äh äh Rückblick, ne?
Ja wir ich plane ja so, dass wir vielleicht mal dann im Rahmen dieser Sommerpause oder im Anschluss an diese kleine zwei, drei Wochen Sommerpause mal so ein ein äh größere eine Rückblickgala machen,
Wir lehnen uns zurück und äh blicken wieder auf das große Ganze. Mal schauen, wer welcher Gast sich da vielleicht anbietet.
sicherlich konkrete Vorstellungen und dann äh wenn dann das politische Tagesgeschehen,
Ja, wenn wir dann wieder in dem Bereich sind, zu dem Helmut Schmidt sich nicht äußert, das fand ich ja sehr schön. Mein Lieblingshemd-Schmidt-Sitat,
Guido Westerwelle, das Tagespolitik, da äußere ich mich nicht zu.
komplette Mann ist Tagespolitik. Ja ähm wenn wir dann wieder äh uns der Tagespolitik zuwenden. Aber so zwischenzeitlich so ein bisschen den Helmut Schmidt der Meta-Ebene, den brauchen wir eigentlich noch.
Wenn ihr nicht so viel raucht.
Ja, mal gucken. Äh vielleicht fällt uns da jemand ein. Die Hörer dürfen natürlich sehr gerne jemanden vorschlagen.
Dampfender Schlot. Na gut, aber jetzt zurück zu Tagespolitik,
Der Helmut spitzt sich ja nicht drum, kümmert.
Irgendeiner muss es ja machen.
Genau.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
da sind jetzt eigentlich die Dinge eingetreten, von denen wir schon so lange gesprochen haben, also es wurden zwei Klagen eingereicht äh vor dem,
EuGH äh heißt das Gericht ja dann glaube ich. Und zwar ähm die Klage gegen Deutschland. Darüber wegen nicht äh Einhaltung der.
Also die Klage der EU-Kommission, genau.
Gegen Deutschland wegen Nichteinhaltung der Richtlinie, das ist jene Klage,
mit der ja lange Zeit große äh große äh mediale Panik verbreitet werden sollte von Befürwortern der äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wo es darum ging, dass äh Millionen,
Strafzahlungen ähm drohen
Ähm und jetzt letztendlich aber zumindest keine Nachzahlungen für vergangene Versäumnisse, sondern allenfalls eine Strafzahlung für zukünftige Versäumnisse im Raume steht. Wir hatten das im Logbuch Netzpolitik dreiundzwanzig, glaube ich, ausführlich,
behandelt. Diese Klage wurde jetzt eingereicht. Ja, wunderbar, liegt da jetzt. Äh direkt neben einer Klage, von der wir auch schon öfter gesprochen hatten.
Äh und zwar die des irischen Hykord, der nämlich genau die Prüfung der Richtlinie durch den EUGH ähm Anrei anregen möchte. Das war eine Klage, bei der wir,
Aufgrund der medialen Berichterstattung eigentlich schon immer davon ausgegangen waren, dass sie längst äh anhängig wäre,
dann feststellten, sie ist es nicht und äh,
um ihre Existenz fürchteten? Nun jedoch ist sie tatsächlich, nachdem man ein Jahr drüber gesprochen hat, äh auch tatsächlich dort eingegangen, das heißt, sie liegt jetzt auch dort auf dem Tisch. Da geht es also wirklich um die,
Prüfung der Richtlinie zu Speicherung selber auf Vereinbarkeit mit den Grundlagenverträgen der Europäischen Union.
Ähm und die weiterhin ja seit langer Zeit sehnsüchtig erwartete Überarbeitung der Richtlinie. Ähm,
Die wird dieses Jahr wohl nicht mehr stattfinden,
wenn man Cecilia Meinströms strömt äh Äußerung zu dem Thema glauben kann. Das heißt, es plätschert so vor sich hin das Thema. Wir haben keine großartigen Neuigkeiten, aber es gibt so die Entwicklung, es läuft irgendwie weiter.
Aber so richtig befasst und will sich damit jetzt auch grade keiner.
Das läuft, ne? Ich meine immerhin so diese Klage von damals monatelang gesprochen, ja, von der irischen Klage haben wir jahrelang gesprochen oder ein gutes Jahr gesprochen.
Ich meine nur der Ball liegt jetzt eher bei den Gerichten als bei der Politik.
Genau. Ja, wird man mal ja genau, die im Moment will da irgendwie keiner dran. Ähm weil vermutlich auch allen klar ist, wenn das,
dass das Thema irgendwie mit dem Thema, macht man wenig Punkte, ne?
Vor allem, wenn man irgendwie wie die Malmström kommt, glaube ich, eher aus dem liberalen Bereich, wenn die dann irgendwie nochmal wiedergewählt werden will und so will sie wahrscheinlich nicht eine Debatte zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben. Also es
wäre jetzt naheliegend, dass das auch äh ein ein äh ein netter Nebeneffekt dessen ist, dass sie diese Überarbeitung der Richtlinie erstmal auf die lange Bank schiebt.
Ja, das war's schon zu dem Thema.
Kurzes Update, kann.
Okay. Außerdem gab's ja äh dann doch eine sehr erfreuliche äh äh Nachricht, wie ich finde. Ähm.
Ja
Zum Thema Nutzen Nutzung offener WLANs, wo wir ja auch schon ein paar Mal hier äh drüber gesprochen haben. Das ist ja immer so problematisch äh ist und die Berliner Kaffee ist jetzt äh schon durchdrehen.
Genau, da gab es also wir erinnern uns, da geht's darum, man hat irgendwie ein offenes WLAN, wo jeder rein kann und dann könnten natürlich auch Personen sich in diesem WLAN äh irgendwie dazu,
motiviert fühlen äh im im Schatten der Anonymität ähm,
Inakzeptables Verhalten zu zeigen, zum Beispiel böse Kommentare unter einen Artikel zu schreiben oder eine Datei herunterzuladen und zu verbreiten
zu verbreiten, das Urheberrecht so in der Form nicht vorsieht. Und ähm es geht da also eigentlich um die ähm,
Haftung, vor der sich da irgendwie geschützt werden soll, von Seiten des Anbieters. Auch da hatten wir ja schon drüber gesprochen, die entsprechende Folge verlinken wir nochmal. Und jetzt gab es also vor dem Landgericht München
einen Fall, da wurde äh also ein Fall verhandelt, da hatte jemand ein Hotspot betrieben ohne seine Nutzer zu identifizieren.
Mhm. Quasi so ein Gästenetz, ein offenes.
Genau. Und dann wurde er verklagt von einem anderen Hotspotbetreiber, der das empfand, als würde er sich dieserjenige dadurch einen Wettbewerbsvorteil,
ähm verschaffen. Also er hat gesagt, ich betreibe hier meine ordnungsgemäß mit Identifizierung,
Und da hinten ist einer, der macht das ohne. Das ist irgendwie für die Nutzer einfacher und deswegen hat der einen Wettbewerbsvorteil mir gegenüber. Und deswegen verklage ich den.
Ja, also ich meine, völlig klar, hätte ich auch gemacht, ne? Einleuchten,
So, ich meine, so eine Geisteshaltung ist ja klar, ne, also.
Genau. Der andere Supermarkt hat äh keine Treppen äh am Eingang.
Den verklag ich.
Sage ich, wie kann er denn überhaupt nur, ja? Und da muss jetzt sofort Stacheldraht aufgezogen.
Interessanter Punkt, warum hat er verklagt? Weil er davon ausgegangen ist, dass es eine gesetzliche Notwendigkeit gibt, die Nutzer zu ähm zu identifizieren.
War dann sozusagen auch der Knackpunkt jetzt hier in der Entscheidung. Das worum womit sich das Gericht im Wesentlichen beschäftigt hat, ob's denn sowas gibt.
Und das Gericht hat, also er nahm quasi an, dass es eine gesetzliche Pflicht gibt und er wollte im Prinzip dann den anderen
dazu per Gerichtsurteil nötigen, das auch zu tun, beziehungsweise dann wahrscheinlich noch irgendeine Entschädigung zu zahlen
da wusste man dann nochmal eben genau schauen was sie alles haben wollen. Auf jeden Fall hat das Gericht die Klage abgewiesen und dieses Urteil ist jetzt rechtskräftig. Das heißt, das Landgericht München eins hat gesagt,
Man muss nicht seine äh Hotspot-Nutzer identifizieren können,
So, das heißt, erstmal anonyme Hotspot-Nutzung ist also oder anonymes Anbieten von Hotspots ist legal, ist in Ordnung und jetzt kommt vom AK Vorrat eine sehr interessante,
Anmerkungen dazu, nämlich dass wenn es nicht notwendig ist,
Seine Hotspot Nutzer zu identifizieren, dann wäre es also nach,
Wenn dein Internet hier gehen würde, könnte ich das jetzt nachlesen. Äh dann wäre es also nach Telekommunikation sonstwas Gedönsgesetz, äh sobald hier die Seite geladen hat, äh zitiere ich da den richtigen Paragraphen, auch,
quasi nicht in Ordnung das zu tun, weil da ja steht, man soll nur die Daten äh organisieren, die äh unbedingt notwendig sind.
Ja, sonst ist es ja eine eine Datenspeicherung über Gebühr quasi, mehr als nötig und das ist äh ah, interessant.
Und so, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob diese Argumentation, ach nee, nix, dein Internet ist super, äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist temporal. Ja, aber.
Mal die Seite auf Vorrat gespeichert, dann wäre das jetzt nicht passiert.
Ja, ja. Ich fahre jetzt noch mal bei Netzpotheke auf, weil wir wollen halt grade bei den juristischen Themen, wo ich äh hm,
Telekommunikationsgesetz, ja? Das Telekommunikationsgesetz verbietet die Erhebung nicht erforderlicher Daten.
Also handeln alle äh Anbieter kostenlose Hotspots rechtwidrig, die von Nutzern zur Zeit noch eine Anmeldung oder Registrierung verlangen, bevor sie den Zugang freigeben.
Diese Praxis muss jetzt ein Ende finden. Sehr argument finde ich sehr.
Das ist wirklich eine echt coole äh und vor allem auch absolut nachvollziehbare Argumentation, ne. Also im im im Sinne des äh äh Gesetzestextes.
Ja, finde ich auch völlig okay. Also ich äh mich ärgern ohnehin diese Hotspots, bei denen man sich.
Ich sage nur Hotels.
Hotel Hotspot. Also wenn ich schon sehe, Hotel mit Internet, ne, da denkst du, ich gehe ja lieber ein Hotel ohne Internet, da weiß man, was man hat.
Allerdings, er ist auch erstaunlich,
wie wenig Hotelbetreiber darüber nachdenken, wie so die Userexperience ist, ne? Ich meine, ein Hotel ist etwas, das ist eine Dienstleistung, die mir sozusagen
Das Verweilen, das temporäre Verweilen an einem anderen Ort so leicht wie möglich machen soll.
kommt da rein, man hat da ein Klo im selben Raum, lalala, Wasser fließt, Strom fließt, Fernseher ist da, et cetera. So und jetzt Internet.
Da muss runter gehen, dann kriegst du bei bei vielen kleinen unabhängigen Hotels kriegst du dann diese diese Codes da ausgedruckt.
Genau. Ja. Und diese Codes sind dann auch noch so bekloppt,
Du, ich meine, so ein Code, okay, meinetwegen, ne, aber irgend so ein dusseliger Programmierer, ja, der so überhaupt nicht darüber nachdenkt, wie so die User-Experience ist,
Ist dann erstmal der Meinung, man müsste sowohl einen Login als auch ein Passwort machen, wobei das Login und das Passwort genauso kryptische Zeichenketten sind, was man sich überhaupt noch fragt, warum man das überhaupt noch.
Det haben wir jetzt schon immer so gemacht.
Ja, also, ja, so geht doch ein Login irgendwie, Login und Passwort, so. Ich meine, dass da man da gar kein Account hat und die Eingabe eines Namens, weil man ja auch nie ein Passwort dazu ändern kann, totaler Bullshit ist und vollkommen ausreichend würde, überhaupt nur eine ID einzugeben
Das ist schon mal so äh das Erste, was krankhaft ist.
Dann ist es
häufig auf zwölf Stunden der Zugang begrenzt, sodass du, wenn du, weiß ich nicht, abends gegen, sagen wir mal, neunzehn Uhr oder zwanzig Uhr im Hotel anfängst, irgendwie Internet zu nutzen und dann morgens aufwachst, erstmal schon mal wieder schön kein Internet hast?
Ja oder zumindest irgendwie nochmal deinen Browser starten musst, um dann irgendwie wieder diese bekloppte Seite auszufüllen, überhaupt diese ganzen Reader rechts, die einem alle Browser Tabs äh äh kaputt.
Dann geht alles an und sagt, dann geht der Mailkleid an und sagt, hier das SSL-Zertifikat, was wir präsentiert wird, passt nicht.
Ist so, es ist einfach witzig. Also, sollte uns irgendwelche Hotelbesitzer zuhören, kann ich nur sagen.
Fenster.
Ah, Swisscom ist das Schlimmste.
Lassen sie dieses Fenster auf, damit wir wissen, dass warum auch immer. Also das lassen sie bloß dieses Fenster auf.
Damit wir wissen, dass dass sie immer noch Interesse am Internet haben.
Dann, dann machst du deinen VPN an, weil du ja irgendwie diesem mit sowas willst ja nicht,
tun haben. So und dann klappt das, aber natürlich dann lässt du diese Seite auf, dann merkt diese Seite aber auf einmal, ich werde irgendwie vom VPN gepinkt und das kann ja, der ist ja gar nicht bei mir, hier läuft irgendwas drehen wir den mal sicherheitshalber das Internet ab,
Also du kriegst es ist Hotel WLAN, Hotspot.
Man müsste eigentlich mal so eine Blacklist machen,
Also so eine so eine so eine so eine so eine Map, wo die Hotels drauf sind, wo einfach ihre Internetqualität äh bewertet wird. So, ja, also alles, was schon mal so einen Hotspot hat, kann.
Hat schon verloren.
Kann einfach nicht besser als gelb werden, ja? Und wenn's halt so ein richtig dramatisch schlechter Hotspot ist mit all diesen ganzen äh Parametern, beklopptes Log-in.
Über rot in schwarz, in schwarz, schwarz.
Genau, Rot ist schon schlimm und schwarz ist sozusagen der Tod
und grün ist alles, wo das im Preis enthalten ist, wo du keine Bandbreitenbegrenzung hast, wo du keine Portsperren hast, wo du keinen Login hast, wo du äh mit all deinen Geräten arbeiten kannst, die du hast, ja?
Stimmt, das ist ja dann auch noch eben, dann kommst du da an und sagst so, ja ich hätte gerne viermal Internet. Wofür brauchen sie denn so viel Internet? Ja, ich habe hier ein äh iPhone, ein iPad, äh ein MacBook, äh einen brauche ich so nebenbei, wenn mal, wenn mal jemand zu Besuch kommt, weil wenn jemand zu Besuch kommt, will's ja auch Internet haben,
Das kann aber nicht sein. Da müssen sie doch mal einen Chef fragen.
Es ist ja mittlerweile auch durchaus zu machen, wenn man jetzt irgendwie da so einen Radioserver aufsetzt, was eher eine sinnvolle Sache ist, dann kannst du ja jedem Kunden auch ein Passwort geben, mit dem er beliebig viele Geräte ins WLAN,
so und dann dann ist halt der diese Abfrage des Codes zum Zeitpunkt des Zutritts zum WLAN und nicht danach, wenn alle da Programme schon denken.
Es ist alles, es ist alles.
Internet ist schon da. Also ich äh äh ich äh habe immer genug äh Energie, mich darüber aufzuregen.
Wir können ja mal ein RFC Schreiben zur Bewertung, zur allgemeinen internationalen Bewertung von Hotspots. Also eine Stufe Stufe orange, irgendwie so, es ist furchtbar, aber es geht. Und dann kommt da drunter noch rot und schwarz,
grün werdet, also.
Oder einfach da mal eine schöne Webseite, my Hotel dot com,
Gibst du da irgendwie äh äh die Bewertung ein, so also halt so richtig so ein so ein so ein schwarzer äh wie sagt man das, so eine schwarze Liste.
Ansonsten kann ich noch äh empfehlen.
Das Schwarzbuch des Internets.
DNS. Kann man da noch irgendwie googeln, wenn man Internet hat? Das äh hilft dann manchmal,
Äh ja, also Hotspots ganz schlimm. Und jetzt haben wir also ein schönes die Münchner. Hätte auch keiner gedacht, dass die Münchener nochmal irgendwie durch seine progressive Position irgendwie hervortreten würden. Ähm und lassen uns jetzt hoffen, dass man irgendwann vielleicht die Hotspot-Problematik los wird, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, bei den Gerichten ist irgendwie auch alles andersrum. Da sind ja eher die Hamburger, also die Konservative.
Du, ich, ich glaube da, das Interessante war, ähm man hat wahrscheinlich einfach nur in diesem Falle Glück gehabt, dass das vor so einem ähm Wirtschaftsgericht dann offensichtlich war, ne, wenn's da um Wettbewerbsvorteile geht und so. Und da haben die wahrscheinlich einfach geguckt, so äh,
muss man das machen? Nee, braucht man nicht alles klar, zack, bumm, hier abgewiesen. Rechtskräftig, dann nachher irgendwie den Memo.
Ja.
Dann gab's noch ein ähm,
schönen Pfeil hier mit wenn wir mit von schlechtem Internet reden. Ähm Netzneutralitätsverletzung
ähm da hat also dann,
Fefe mal irgendwie ein paar Benchmarks seiner Internet Connection gemacht und hat also festgestellt, dass bestimmte Verbindungen geshaped waren und das aber
immer, wenn irgendwie er auf Speed-Test gegangen ist, DSS-Spie-Test, das äh sehr schnell immer alles war. Man hat dann die Theorie entwickelt, dass ähm,
sein Kabelanbieter ähm quasi eine ein Mechanismus hat, der dann feststellt.
Wenn jemand einen Speedtest macht und diesen also ganz besonders priorisiert, damit der Nutzer,
auch wirklich das Gefühl hat, dass seine Leitung völlig in Ordnung ist und an anderen Stellen dann eben den Traffic irgendwie versucht zu manipulieren.
ähm wie genau diese Diagnose jetzt ist,
Wie, wie, wie fest diese Diagnose ist, darüber gab's dann äh
Diskussionen, Kabel hat das dann relativ schwammig dementiert. Das Entscheidende ist, ähm das hat der Andre dann auch bei Netzpolitik Org sehr ordentlich herausgearbeitet. Ist das ist,
relativ offensichtlich ist, dass diese äh Netznetralitätsverletzungen stattfinden und,
Absolut intransparent ist, unter welchen Bedingungen und wie die Provider das dann machen. Genau das war ja immer der zentrale Alptraum in der Netzneutralitätsdebatte.
Was ist denn jetzt eigentlich das Neue, weil wir hatten das ja schon mal äh bei Logbuch äh Display achtundzwanzig haben wir da ja auch schon über diese Fallsharings.
Ja, dass das Neue war, dass also äh Shaping meinte festzustellen bei Diensten, die
kein Fallsharing betreffen, zweitens, dass er niemals äh diesen dieses Trafficlimit erreicht hatte, zu dem sie behaupten würden, sie würden bremsen,
ja? Ähm.
Und drittens, dass er also bei bestimmten Speed-Test-Verbindungen dann eben,
festgestellt hat, dass da kein stattfindet. Das wäre also das wären so die drei Neuigkeiten an dieser Angelegenheit,
und das Entscheidende eben, dass auf Nachfrage
überhaupt keine Transparenz von von Kabel irgendwie da steht. Ja, die haben ja auch in ihr diese AGB-Teil war ja auch sehr, äh, den wir in einem einer vorangefolgen vorangegangenen Folge diskutiert hatten. War ja auch sehr schwammig, dass sie bestimmte Dienste, bestimmte Verbindungen
etwas drosseln können und so weiter, ja?
Aber was sie genau machen, welche Regeln, also was kaufe ich da? Was ist, was ist an meinem Internet? Äh was wird an meinem Internet verstellt? Darüber gibt's also keine klare Transparenz. Ist auch relativ,
Also aus von technischer Perspektive relativ klar, warum es da keine Transparenz gibt, weil wenn du ernsthaft ähm ausbremsen willst, dann möchtest du natürlich deinen
Kunden, die er in dem Fall deine Gegner sind,
nicht verraten nach welchen Regeln du das machst beziehungsweise wie es die wie es diese Regeln auch im am laufenden Bande anpassen müssen ja?
Ähm insofern, ja, also wir haben genau diesen, dieser Fall ist, also da, wir haben
Verletzungen und es gibt keine Transparenz, ja? Also ganz genau der Alptraum, das, wovor alle Netzneutralitätsbefürworter immer warnen. Das ist das, was wir jetzt hier also ganz klar beobachten,
Andre hatte dann noch zitiert eine Studie, die schon im Mai von Neli Cruz äh unserer EU-Kommissarin,
für die Freiheit, ja? Für die Freiheit und das Leben ähm.
Veröffentlicht wurde oder von ihrem Auftrag durchgeführt wurde, dass sie also sagt, circa zwanzig Prozent bis fünfzig Prozent der mobilen Internet,
Anschlüsse haben laut Vertrag ähm,
Einschränkungen in der Netznetralität, insbesondere dann so im Voiceover IP Bereich und im. Ähm und bei den,
äh Kabel Operators äh also bei den Festnetzanschlüssen sind es um die zwanzig Prozent,
in jetzt äh über äh gemessen in äh über alle EU-Mitgliedsstaaten. Ähm bei den zwanzig Prozent der Festnetzoperation äh äh Operators ist es dann also hauptsächlich hier,
Ähm so, das heißt, wir haben also relativ klar diesen Fall, dass sie bestimmte Protokolle,
Da ausbremsen bestimmte Dienste, bestimmte Dienste, Anbieter und äh das natürlich absolut intransparent machen. Nun ist einfach jetzt erstmal ein Fakt,
Ist auch kein neuer Fakt ist, aber äh interessant da jedes Mal wieder darauf hinzuweisen, weil es ja immer noch in Deutschland die vorherrschende Meinung ist, dass das regelt dann der Markt.
Ja ja
vielleicht regelt's der Markt ja auch, weil ich denke, man sollte immer allen, die so ein bisschen Einblick haben in so Speed-Test und Protest et cetera, ruhig mal ermutigen, äh den eigenen Provider gegebenenfalls, wenn man die Möglichkeit hat, auch die Provider von Freunden et cetera mal genau auf solche Profile hin
zu überprüfen und vielleicht etabliert sich ja mal so eine Monitoring-Zeit, weißt du?
Es gibt die Monitoring Zeit, ne? Es äh ja und zwar ist das ähm Respekt meinet.
Respekt, meinet, das ist von den,
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, darf ich sagen, wer das gemacht hat? Ja, wahrscheinlich. Also, läuft, glaube ich, unter äh unter und lag vor der Tür, die Net, so das ist so deren Schirmherrschaft. Ich weiß auch, wer die Seite gecodet hat, der steht aber nicht hierbei, also äh.
Warum soll man das nicht sagen?
Weiß ich nicht, das ist jemand, der da schon öfter mir gesagt hat, dass er, wenn es da nicht steht, das auch nicht.
Na gut, also was auf der Webseite steht, ist halt bitter Freedom-Mindlaturnett. Ja, okay, was machen die?
Da kannst du.
Werden wirklich die Reports.
Ein Fall ähm melden und sagen hier, was weiß ich, nehmen wir mal als Beispiel, ich bin bei dem Anbieter TIlenor in Ungarn,
Und ähm ich habe den Vertrag Internetpraktikum und der der Dienst-Fight-Sharing ist dort verlangsamt im Mobilfunknetz.
meldet man das und dann können andere klicken und sagen, ja, bei mir auch. Ja, Holland wo davon, also bei bei ähm,
Bei ähm Mobilanbietern ist das dann nicht so überraschend, dass man da Netzneutralitätsverletzungen feststellt. Ähm die machen's ja wirklich äh sehr, sehr klar und selbst schon eigentlich von Beginn an,
ähm bei Festnetzanbietern ist das natürlich dann nochmal um einiges spannender.
Mhm. Das sind so einzelne Vorfälle und so. Interessanter wäre ja, wenn's äh sagen wir mal eine eine Testsoftware gäbe. Ja.
Ja, gibt's auch, die wird, also das, da sind äh ist wohl offiziell gerade diejenige, die man da haben möchte.
Neubot. Also in EU-Bot.
Ähm und ansonsten haben sie hier 'n Glas Nost empfehlen sie noch.
Java ist das.
Dass wir jetzt also auf auf äh auf Rechnern und dann gibt's noch ein paar äh hier Android und so was äh,
und so, also gibt's relativ viel, ja? Ich glaube aber, dass Newboard der einzige ist, der dann wirklich auch mal äh Test äh Verbindung zwischen,
seinen Einzelnen Instanzen herstellt. Also ich meine das das Sinnvolle zum zu prüfen von Netzneutralitätsverletzung wäre ja eben einfach zwischen zwei Usern mal unterschiedliche Protokolle zu sprechen. Ne fängst du halt mal an und sprichst mal ein bisschen HTTP und guckst mal, wie sich das verhält.
schließen wir FDP und dann fängt's mal an und guckst, wie sich die Bandbreite ändert, wenn du auf einmal äh sage ich mal klassischen Bitcoin-Traffic zwischen beiden machst,
Und das scheint also dieser Newboard ähm in neueren Versionen jetzt auch tatsächlich mal zu machen,
Und er wird also da empfohlen, ja. Da gibt's also dann eine Tutorial, nimm mal den Newboard, benutze den und ähm wenn dir der wenn der dir dann etwas ausschmeißt, dann melde das bei Respektmanage.
Interessant, interessant. Ähm ja, da verlinken wir dann mal drauf, ne? Auf die beiden.
Das da verlinken wir mal drauf.
Sachen. Neubot. Alles neu macht der Bot.
Ja, so viel zu Netzwerk, also das Thema ähm,
wie gesagt, ich betone das deshalb, weil ja die äh Argumentation von Seiten CDU, CSU, FDP,
Ähm hauptsächlich ist, ja, äh das ist sich in den theoretisches Problem. Ja und äh,
das ist aber jetzt schon inzwischen ein sehr Praktisches.
Ja gibt's noch was zu sagen eigentlich nicht.
Machen wir ein nächstes Thema.
Nächstes Thema.
Ja? Und zwar das für das was eine sehr sehr schöne Geschichte.
Die Posse der Woche.
Poster der Woche ähm vielleicht etwas länger ausholen. In in London findet ja jetzt die Olympiade statt.
Und ähm das Olympische, also die Marke Olympiade,
ist also wird mit mit allen Waffen und allem Elan dieser Welt von dem äh von den Rechteinhabern dieser Marke geschützt.
Es gab da also schon vor Monaten Fälle in London, wo dann der
pakistanische Spätkaufbesitzer sich irgendwie mit dem Wachsmalstift irgendwie die olympischen Ringe ins Fenster gemalt hat und dann irgendwie Polizei vorbeikam
und äh ihn gezwungen hat, äh diese dieses Symbol nicht zu nutzen, weil er da nicht das Recht dran hat und kein offizieller Partner ist,
Also es wird äh bei Olympiade ist das also so ähm
jeder, der mit diesem Logo werben möchte, muss dann eben offizieller Partner sein und da sehr viel sehr viel Geld für bezahlen.
Mhm.
Ähm und jeder, der,
Nicht offizieller Partner ist, hat eben auch in keiner Form das Recht, irgendwie sich damit zu assoziieren. Und jetzt ähm viel ähm,
Na, Frankfurt, genau, erzähle ich mal noch den den schöneren Teil der Geschichte zuerst. Es gibt da nämlich diese Protestgruppe, die Space High Checkers in London. Das ist so ein Grüppchen, die ähm auch seit einiger Zeit ganz äh eng verbandelt sind, so mit den
idealen und den Menschen, der hedonistischen Internationale und die haben dann die
weil man ja offiziell sein muss, ja? In allem, also es gibt das offizielle Getränk, es gibt das offizielle Fahrrad, es gibt das offizielle Auto, die offizielle Uhr, ja? Und die haben gegründet,
die offiziellen äh Protestiere, also die Official Protestes, auf die Lande Olympic Games, ja? Und bei dieser Webseite,
Sehr schön. Also da gibt's dann gibt's dann T-Shirt, ne? Und bei dieser Webseite kannst du dich registrieren, ja? Mit dem und da steht also sehr klar, ne?
Vor Tickets. Also man muss sich registrieren,
und man muss offizieller ähm Demonstrant sein, ja?
Mal, da ist die Bahnsteigkarte für die äh Proteste, deutsche Kultur jetzt auch in Britannien.
Sie werden also, Sie werden dann, also äh ich denke, von denen wird mit sehr schönen äh Aktionen zu rechnen sein. Selbstverständlich haben sie auch schon angekündigt, dass sie ihre, ihre Rechte als offizielle,
Protestierer ähm auch dann natürlich gegenüber anderen Protestierern wahrnehmen und durchsetzen werden, ja?
Super.
Hatten auch dann schon vor äh vor Monaten,
Ärger mit den olympischen Komitee, weil sie irgendwie auf die gelingt hatten oder irgendwie deren Logo irgendwie mit drin haben und so und äh ihr Twitter-Account wurde dann gesperrt und so, ja.
Also dieses diese diese gerade in London ähm ist das halt dann wirklich ähm,
da kriegst du die Briten dann schon, ne? Wenn, wenn also wie gesagt, so dieses natürlich will jeder ähm,
seinen Olympiakram haben und wenn wenn dann halt dieses olympische Komitee oder wie auch immer auch immer diese Gruppe dann da heißt äh in der Form da den Quatsch durchsetzt, dann ähm,
Lassen sich selbst die Briten das nicht mehr gefallen.
Na ja, ich meine, das ist ja so ein bisschen der Sommer, der der Großveranstaltung in äh Unterdrückerischen und äh Überwachungsstaatsorientierten äh äh,
Ländern so, ne, er ist Aserbaidschan mit dem Eurovision Song Contest, dann Ukraine mit der Fußball-Europameisterschaft.
Und jetzt London.
Und jetzt auch noch die Briten irgendwie, ja so äh für jeden für jeden Gast und für jeden äh
äh für jede Medaille gibt's auch irgendwie einen Satz von Kameras.
Haben die sich da nicht jetzt irgendwie sechzehn sechzehntausend Militärs noch in die Stadt geholt oder so.
Ja, die haben das Problem, dass einfach auch äh die ganze äh Polizei ohnehin schon total,
überlastet ist und dann haben sie eben für die Durchführung der Sicherheitsmaßnahmen, die geplant waren, vor allem auch so private Security-Firmen irgendwie angelacht, die jetzt allerdings ein paar Wochen vor dem Start die Hände gehoben haben, gesagt haben, äh.
Wir kriegen's nicht hin, wir haben irgendwie nicht genug Leute und jetzt haben sie da quasi nochmal ein Defizit, was sie äh stopfen müssen, was sie aber mit Polizei nicht gestopft bekommen, weil das war ja schon zur Entlastung der Polizei überhaupt gedacht. Und jetzt äh rekrutieren sie halt ihre Armee,
quasi, ja? Also auch ein schönes Gefühl, da irgendwie bei so einem entspannten Fest der Freundschaft
und der internationalen Verbrüderungen und Offenheit und Weltoffenheit und Pipapo rumzusitzen und du weißt, dass irgendwie Leute äh aus dem,
äh äh dich vielleicht schon im Fadenkreuz haben, äh für den Fall, dass du irgendwie das offizielle Protest-T-Shirt äh ausschaltest und dann wirst du halt auch erstmal präventiv erschossen, ja? Also es ist
total absurd. Ich meine Olympics, muss ich sagen. Also es ist auch im Gegensatz zu Fußball Europameisterschaft. Lässt mich halt,
diese Veranstaltung auch inhaltlich vollständig kalt. Also das kann einfach mit Olympia nichts anfangen,
weiß nicht, wie es dir geht. Ich weiß, es gibt dann Leute, die finden das irgendwie toll, die ganze Zeit irgendwelchen Weitspringern äh zuzuschauen, aber das hat für mich einfach null Reiz, ja? Vor allem immer so dieses.
Die mochte ich schon im Sportunterricht nicht.
Diese, diese Streber.
Sportstreber, weißt du? Hier.
Nix in der Birne aber schnell laufen können. Na toll. Naja, soll ja jeder seinen Spaß haben,
Veranstaltung, aber ich finde, dass Olympia,
selbst als Event zeigt einfach, dass das mittlerweile einfach alles in die falsche Richtung geht mit Großveranstaltungen. Es betrifft natürlich genauso auch die Fußball- und sonstigen äh äh Meisterschaften. Das ist einfach mal nicht schön. Zumal eben an der Stelle auch wirklich,
ähm das Recht der Länder dann auch irgendwie mit mit Füßen getreten wird. Das hat man wunderbar gesehen,
IFA äh äh ja bei den Fußballweltmeisterschaften, mit welchen Bedingungen diese Länder äh letzten Endes dort antreten müssen,
vor allem auch im Konflikt mit ihrer eigenen Gesetzeslage. Ja, dass quasi diesen Unternehmungen wie Olympia und äh der FIFA Rechte eingeräumt werden müssen, die das Recht eigentlich gar nicht vorsieht,
ja? Also die sozusagen im Gegen.
Ja, also das ist ganz.
Satz stehen zu all dem, was halt normalerweise Firmen zugestanden werden darf.
Länder, die Länder reißen sich darum, weil sie halt irgendwie meinen, dass das irgendwie äh natürlich so die Stadt äh für die nächsten zehn Jahre enorm attraktiv machen wird und.
In der Regel nicht der Fall. Wenig Ausnahme.
In der Regel nicht der Fall und insbesondere nicht der Fall, dass da irgendwie äh ernsthaft Infrastruktur entsteht oder oder irgendwie, sage ich mal, äh ähm die,
lokale Wirtschaft irgendwie darunter äh äh ein ein nennenswerten Boost erfährt, ne, außer jetzt irgendwie jene,
die.
So lokal ist, dass sie sich im Wesentlichen um die äh beteiligten Politiker herum äh arrangiert. Die lokale Wirtschaft, die profitiert schon sehr wohl, ne.
Und wie gesagt, solche Fälle, wie das dann da in London den den kleinen Spätkaufbetreibern irgendwie äh ey, du hast hier das Symbol eines Stabhofspringers im Schaufenster, der machst du aber wieder weg. Also, also.
Ja, ja. Das geht gar.
Das ist also geht gar nicht. Aber kommen wir kommen wir vielleicht zum zum Thema. Ähm nämlich.
Echt zum Thema.
Ja äh im Rahmen dieser Verteidigung der Rechte der Olympiade. Also das ist ja so dieses Kernding, ja, also wir haben jetzt die Protestes, also wie gesagt, Space High Check hast sowieso super Leute, kann ich nur empfehlen. Ähm,
Und in den Nutzungsbedingungen der Website,
Der offiziellen London zwanzig zwölf Website steht dann drin, in den AGBs quasi, in den Bedingungen, die du anerkennst, wenn du diese Seite besuchst,
steht drin, dass du auf diese Seite verlinken darfst, vorausgesetzt du hast einen Text, nur Textlink. Das heißt, du darfst keinen grafischen Link anbringen.
Egal wie der aussieht.
Nur Text-Link. So, AGB, hast du ja gelesen, akzeptiert. So und du darfst nicht einen Link auf der Seite setzen,
Wenn du eine unautorisierte Assoziation zwischen Organisationen, Geschäften, Waren oder Diensten
und der London Olympiade herstellen möchtest. Das heißt, es ist genau das, also quasi der kleine Spätkaufbesitzer darf nicht sagen, ich bin in London, wo zwanzig zwölf eine Olympiade stattfindet mit Link,
das darf der nicht, weil er eine unautorisierte Assoziation der Olympiade mit sich selber herstellt,
Und du ähm du erklärst dich äh einverstanden, dass du die im Rahmen deines Links nicht,
Die Olympiade selber oder andere Offizielle, London zwanzig zwölf Organisationen, deren Aktivitätenprodukte oder Dienste in einem falschen. Ähm,
Missverständlichen ähm oder irgendwie abwertenden ähm Rahmen.
Abwertenden oder sonst wie abzulehnen, also sehr offen gehalten, ne?
Oder in irgendeiner Weise von uns abzulehnen, denn.
Wenn wir das scheiße finden, dann bist du dran.
Ja, also du darfst, um's kurz zu halten, nur auf die linken, ähm, wenn du was Nettes über sie sagst. Und natürlich auch das natürlich trotzdem nicht das Logo nehmen, ja? Also das nicht.
Official Protest das ja eigentlich machen, ne, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Nee, das haben sie, inzwischen machen sie es nicht mehr, ja, also sie haben keinen offiziellen Link mehr dahin, ja, der den, der wurde ihnen dann schon weg verboten.
Aber Sie verwenden doch schon das Logo irgendwie.
Ja, das ist aber, glaube ich, so weit abgewandelt oder so. Ähm ja, es ist nicht das offizielle Logo.
Kannst du mal gucken, wie das eigentlich.
Ja, das offizielle Logo ist irgendwie anders, ja? Vorsichtig, wenn ich jetzt auf die Seite gehst, dann tut man dann nicht mehr. Also wir dürfen da natürlich auch nicht mehr hinlegen, aber wir Linken natürlich oh okay.
Soweit ist es nicht auseinander, würde ich sagen, es ist eigentlich das Logo.
Okay, die die verlangen also, die warten noch auf ihre Klage, okay. Wir werden es sehen, ja.
Ja, die Space Seite, die machen das schon. Da bin ich nämlich ganz zuversichtlich. Das wird noch viel Freude geben. Und ähm ja, also sehr schön, wie wie dieses wie dieses ähm,
Wie die also ihre, wie die Olympiade ihre Rechte da schützt. Und ähm,
das fiel dann irgendwann mal jemandem auf, der der sich die Mühe gemacht hat, diese AGBs zu lesen und wurde dann insbesondere durch äh Corry Doctor und so dann einmal sehr äh,
durchgeheizt dieses Thema. Das Interessante oder was man daran sieht, ist natürlich so, was,
Vertretung und Markenvertretung im Internet oder in Zeiten des Internets,
Offensichtlich bedeuten kann, ne? Also ich find's schon sehr, sehr amüsant, dass die äh dass sie überhaupt auf die Idee kommen, irgendwie zu meinen, wir wir verbieten dir Links.
Ja, ich kann dir sagen, äh was der Grund ist dafür, warum sie das machen.
Naja, ich meine, das Geld, was also das Geld, was hier zu machen, ist mit der Olympiade. Das Geld, wovon sich diese Olympiade ernährt, ist Werbung und vor allem Sponsoring und offizielle, wir sind der Offizielle von hm,
So und genau das versuchen sie einfach zu unterbinden und ich würde ja auch ihnen durchaus zugestehen, dass äh äh so eine Aussage wie äh ihr dürft nicht als offizieller Partner auftreten,
Ja
nachvollziehbare Geschichte ist, weil äh äh das stellt ja einen Werbewert dar ganz offensichtlich, sonst würden sie ja nicht alle hingehen. So und natürlich möchten sie äh verhindern,
dass äh irgendein Unternehmen mit so einer äh da gab's doch auch mal so ein schönes Beispiel, äh war das nicht sogar irgendwie McDonald's oder irgend so ein größere Marke,
irgendeiner Großveranstaltung, die sich schön sozusagen an diesem ganzen Sponsoring vorbei geschummelt hat, indem sie sich,
keiner, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie's wie's war, irgendwie wir sind die inoffiziellen,
Ja, also sozusagen, so, so, so, so, so, so 'n Tanz drumherum gemacht hat und, äh, dann mag es sicherlich 'ne Menge.
Wahrscheinlich tierisch einen für auf den Sack bekommen.
Naja, das weiß ich jetzt nicht alles nicht mehr so ganz genau, aber das es dann eine Menge Leute gibt, die natürlich äh,
ohne jetzt große Summen zu bezahlen, irgendwie so tun wollen, als wären sie irgendwie assoziiert und sich da auch alles Mögliche einfallen lassen, das ist klar und das natürlich auch im Netz, ne.
und da geht diese Formulierung eigentlich hin, ne? Also die nicht autorisierte Assoziation.
Würde jetzt die fetten, die fette Kampagne von meine, also Linus in Corporate würde jetzt fahren, in keiner Weise assoziiert mit der Olympiade. So das wäre einfach das, was ich äh würde mich massiv davon distanzieren.
Genau, aber der kritische Punkt ist halt diese Formulierung mit irgendwie ihr dürft nichts tun, was irgendwie missliegende Rogue ist.
Also das ist ja also diese Formulierung, die verdienen schon äh eine Goldmedaille, ne. Also weil äh wer wer.
Bei mir in den AGB.
Bitte antworten sie mir nicht in irgendeiner Form, wie es mich in die falsche Richtung führen könnte, abfällig ist oder sonstwie,
Zu Widerspruch aufrufen könnte, ja.
Meinen Namen nicht benutzen, entsetzt, indem ich kritisiert werde. Oder in einem Zusammenhang, der mir nicht gefällt.
Oder von dem irgendjemand glauben könnte, dass sie das vorhätten, mich vielleicht unter Umständen zu kritisieren oder sonst wie schlecht dastehen.
Den Anschein erwecken, dass ich nicht der der schönste, beste, tollste von allen.
Genau, meine Chancen bei den Mädchen irgendwie reduzieren könnte. Ja, ja, theoretisch. Ja. Also das, das ist wirklich so äh der der hanebüchene Punkt und das geht natürlich gar nicht.
Aber es zeigt eben, was für einer Welt wir leben und dass wir auch in Zukunft im Themenbereich der Netzpolitik doch den ein oder anderen Lacher doch ähm unterbringen können.
Immer noch. Genau. Ja, auch diese Sendung war natürlich äh hat euch natürlich in die falsche Richtung äh geführt, ja. War auch ein bisschen abfällig.
Ja auch nicht auf die Olympiade.
Genau, das machen wir nicht.
Zwei Wochen Pause.
Ja, genau.
Zwei Wochen Pause und ähm.
Dann kommen wir wieder frisch gestärkt und äh ihr könnt ja die Zeit nutzen hier für ilaboriertes äh Feedback und äh äh Wünsche und Vorschläge und so,
Sicherlich irgendwie das ein oder andere vorstellen über unser Format noch weiter beleben. Äh in der zweiten Jahreshälfte.
Ja, was ich wirklich ganz nett finde, werden so ähm,
Entweder Vorschläge von wen man dann also wie gesagt, es wird irgendwie im Sommer weniger akute Themen geben und da können wir uns sicherlich dann einfach mal dafür dann bestimmten Themen vertiefend widmen
und da fände ich's echt schön, also Vorschläge von,
wem man was so Themen sind oder Gesprächspartner sind, die äh die euch interessieren. Ähm gerne auch äh man kann sich auch selber vorschlagen, es machen ja auch.
Ausnahmsweise, ja?
Man darf sich auch selber vorschlag.
Aber natürlich auf eine Art und Weise, die nicht irreführend ist oder abwertend sonst wie ablehnen, ja genau.
Abwertend gegenüber Leckbuch auf gar keinen Fall, ja.
Scheiße, die Domäne ist jetzt schon mal weg. Ach nee, wir senden ja nicht live, die die können wir uns doch sichern.
Das nehmen wir raus.
Genau.
Und das macht ihr einfach. Und ansonsten habt ihr einfach äh äh Spaß äh äh haltet den Bauch in die Sonne und äh.
Und schaut euch ein bisschen Space-Highters-Kram an in der Zeit. Die Jungs sind echt fit. Mädels auch. Nette Mädels.
Und hört mal die anderen Podcasts noch nicht gehört habt nach. Damit ihr auf dem Stand seid. Ja, das war's. Auf Wiederhören. Bis bald.
Auf Wiederhören.